there's a lot of discussion today about
stuff like the minimum wage or a living
wage it's an interesting discussion to
me and an interesting argument on a lot
of fronts one is from a practical
mathematical standpoint on the actual
minimum wage everybody's all worried
that well you can't live on the minimum
wage you can't live on the minimum wage
you can't live on them people can't make
it on the minimum wage and no one does
really know I mean statistically the
Bureau of Labor Statistics says that
less than one percent of Americans are
attempting to operate their households
while the primary breadwinners or winner
is making minimum wage less than 1% it's
actually less than 1/2 of 1% and so
raising the minimum wage federally does
almost nothing mathematically
mechanically statistically our view on a
measuring it's a bunch of crap it
doesn't do anything the people that make
minimum wage are primarily part-time
workers and they're primarily teenagers
I don't even believe in the minimum wage
and here's why hi I've never worked for
minimum wage and I would never allow
anybody I love to work for minimum wage
I would tell them to do something
different I used to cut grass when I was
12 years old I first started cutting
grass then and my goal was to make
double or triple minimum wage when I was
cutting grass and so I'd priced the yard
fairly what I could get for it and then
I would cut the grass with great
productivity great diligence so that I
could make 2 or 3 times per hour with my
buddies who were down at Burger King
being whopper flippers we're making and
so you know if you don't like the
minimum wage don't work for it oh there
you go
and really the same thing about the
living wage is true it's a social
commentary that honestly is a bunch of
crap because it really doesn't have any
effect on anything this idea that that
you get to tell a company
or an individual what to pay it is out
of my realm I don't get this it's about
freedom say common sense says this is
none of your business
if company a wants to pay a team member
a and employee a certain amount what
business is that of yours if you don't
like what Walmart pays hey don't work
there you don't like what Mickey D's
pays hey don't work there well I don't
work there it's just a social values the
thing I don't I don't believe that they
are a fair corporate citizen well then
don't shop there you know don't shop
there vote with your feet that's called
freedom it's called liberty you get to
decide what's going on if a company is
misbehaving morally at an extreme level
in our culture over time they are run
out of business here's the reason people
like the minimum wage a they believe
they get to tell people what to do and
they don't how to mind their own
business B ah their union contract is
indexed to minimum wage so they want the
minimum wage to go up because it means
they get a pay raise it's not that
they're all socially concerned and so
the next time someone starts bringing up
the minimum wage a its mathematically it
doesn't even exist on a real basis for
real families to really eat on and and B
you need to mind your own business
and see if you don't like it and you
still want to mind someone else's
business
shop somewhere else work somewhere else
it's real easy you don't like what I pay
then don't don't do business with me you
don't like what I pay then don't work
for me it's real easy I've quit jobs
because I didn't get paid enough there
or because they tried to change my pay
in an unfair manner that's a reasonable
thing to do it's a free country and so
this idea we get to tell each other what
to do all the time in the name of your
social morals it's got to stop you guys
it's out of control